the northwest is in need of an emergency
covered response
for weeks there have been concerns about
the rise in cases
the indian variant has been dominating
this part of the uk
today the health secretary confirmed
greater manchester and lancashire
will get extra government support i want
to encourage
everyone in manchester and lancashire
to get the tests on offer we know that
this approach
can work we've seen it work in south
london
and in bolton in stopping
a rise in the number of cases
his announcement of extra vaccines more
testing
and military support may be welcome but
the package comes with caution
minimise travel and only meet people
outside where possible
additional guidance when lockdown should
be completely lifted
in just 13 days i think we've got to
stop hitting one part of the country
against the other
um and i think you know where we have
spikes
we have to do more of this and not put
people into localized lot dance it feels
like it's always the same areas
why i don't understand that um again
i'm not conspiracist or anything but why
why is it always the same areas
five of the uk's highest infection rates
are in greater manchester
whilst the region's mayor has been one
of the government's biggest critics
during the pandemic he welcomed these
new steps
work with us let's do what we need to do
you know let's
leave local lockdowns in in last year
let's not go back to any of that don't
you know worry the public with the
threat of that carry people with us and
i think we could
we can do it boots on the ground in
bolton have helped this town's cases
flatten
the same strategy will now be seen in
neighbouring lancashire
if you look at the percentage of people
who've had two doses
there is quite a variation from as low
as 42 percent in kendall to
uh you know 64.2 percent in scarborough
for instance so it just
goes to show that these places are very
different and they need differential
support
this region has been here before it's
vulnerable to restrictions once again
and tonight over four million people
find themselves staring down the barrel
of a step backwards anybody we speak to
probably said that we've had enough of
it
if they put more guidelines in place
well are people going to stick to them i
understand that it's still a big health
risk and we've got to be careful with
those concerns
i also want to kind of get life going
again because the people that i'm close
to that are at risk
have already been fully protected
against it mental health is
key at this point and the amount of
lockdowns and how we've been messed
around it's just ridiculous it's like
no one's thinking about how this is
affecting us as people
like the rest of the country people here
want to feel full freedom
in two weeks but there's a clear hurdle
on the road out
in zaman rashid sky news manchester